alright so thank you everyone for being
here well that's are a lot of people and
the special thanks to the Academy thank
you so much for this opportunity it's
been quite amazing first of all I really
news I think my family who unfortunately
could not be here tonight my mom dad
stepmom my siblings my amazing
grandparents and everyone else was
supported me along the way i also have a
big thank you to the other people in my
life who are able to be here tonight my
little fan club down in the corner my
incredible producer and film partner
Ramona Ramdeen I will always love the
looks that people give us when we tell
them that a middle aged indian woman and
a 21 year old Caucasian kid are really
good film partners so thank you I need
to have a special thanks to my amazing
mentor from the our Institute of
Jacksonville Nadia ramit are because
without you none of this would be
possible thank you to everyone else who
made this film possible Orlando Zane
Victoria Hillary Keisha Rita Victor
Julia Kyle Corey and everyone else who
was on the cast and crew thank you a
special thanks to Kim Manu and dave
allen thomas who got me interested in
acting and filmmaking in the first place
special thanks to my best friend Jamie
Ratliff and also hunter back at home for
both of you of keeping me from going
crazy for the past month and thank you
to my fellow winners all of you guys
have taught me so much as artists
throughout this whole past week and I
hope that all of us can meet again
sometime down the line thank you
you